there's some tension building among the
Royal Fab Four and even a surprise
appearance by Megan Markel has some
people saying that she was dissing the
Queen Her Royal Highness the Duchess of
Sussex the Duchess stunned the audience
at the British Fashion Awards when she
strode on stage while caressing her baby
bump
[Music]
but what has everyone talking is her
sexy one-shouldered black velvet gown
and strappy sandals they weren't exactly
royal well everything about this outfit
was super daring dare I say very very
sexy right down to the dark nail polish
that she was wearing on her toes and on
her hands the Queen is known to not like
dark nail colors on Royal women she she
finds it vulgar Megan presented an award
to the woman who designed her wedding
dress for Siobhan she the winner this
evening is Claire Witt Keller and while
all eyes were on the pregnant Duchess a
royal source reports that there is still
tension in the royal household though
real feud is between the brothers
apparently Harry is upset that he didn't
get Williams full backing at the start
of the relationship he went mental
when Prince William didn't quite give
Megan the thumbs-up that Harry had been
hoping for so with all the
behind-the-scenes drama
how will the royal spin their Christmas
the four of them will be at Sandringham
for Christmas Day hosted by the Queen
christmas is a time for goodwill and
forgiveness so let's hope we see the
princes do just that
[Music]